samsung's new galaxy s22 ultra is
currently breaking the tech internet not
only on the android side but also for
apple fans because this is the first
time in a while that i think samsung
knocked it out of the park with the
design and feature set and it's giving
apple's iphone 13 pro max some serious
competition so before i get into
comparing all the specs and new features
to see if the new s22 ultra can actually
take the smartphone crown away from
apple i want to get into samsung's
clever master plan for how they're
marketing this new ultra smartphone but
first i want to mention that my wife and
i just had our second son eli and i'm
finally back to work and ready to bring
you guys some more tech related content
so let's jump right into it if you
didn't already know samsung discontinued
the galaxy note flagship phone series
last year when for the first time in
many years they didn't release an
updated model and that really sucked
because we absolutely loved the previous
galaxy note 20 ultra which came with a
beautiful squarish design a built-in s
pen and an amazing camera bump layout
but last year samsung decided to release
their two new foldable phones instead
the z-fold three and the z flip three so
they've basically made it apparent that
their foldable phones have now replaced
the note series as their flagship
because in reality they already have two
high-end smartphone lineups a year the s
series and the foldables so doing all
three including the notes would be too
much so they made just about the best
choice they could have made in my
opinion they simply took the note design
and rebranded it as the s22 ultra with a
design that's almost identical to the
note 20 ultra now this is very clever
because it sets the ultra model apart
from the lower end s22 models which have
a completely different design and let me
add that i absolutely can't stand the
chunky notch that kind of melts into the
frame it just looks horribly ugly so
thankfully they got rid of it for the
ultra model and gave each camera lens
its own separate bump which i think
looks incredibly clean and it's part of
the reason why i think this phone will
be so successful not to mention this
great looking white model and to be
honest the combination of the beautiful
camera layout the matte glass finish the
rounded display edges and the super
clean and high quality display with just
a single camera cut out definitely gives
the iphone 13 pro max a run for its
money because i mean it still has that
ugly notch that i'm honestly getting
sick of and of course it still has the
old usb 2.0
lightning port so the hardware side is
kind of dragging along compared to the
new galaxy s22 ultra now in my opinion i
still really like the camera bump on the
13 pro max better because of the whole
three-step design that looks very clean
and professional but the new one on the
ultra looks very good as well now the
next thing i want to talk about is the
cameras and samsung's honestly doing a
very good job in this department while
apple has caught up pretty well with the
new 13 pro max i've gotta hand it to
samsung because they've been improving
their 108 megapixel main camera over the
past couple of years and now they're
optimizing it for nighttime photos and
videos and i'm really excited to see
some comparisons because it was already
so close with last year's s21 ultra but
the major advantage comes down to the
additional 10x space zoom lens which
pumps out incredibly sharp long range
zoom photos which is something that's
simply not possible on the iphone right
now and we're not rumored to get that
until the iphone 15 pro models but i do
want to mention that we've already
ordered an s22 ultra and we're gonna be
doing our popular unbiased blind camera
comparison so if you're not already
subscribed do so right now so you don't
miss out now moving forward i want to
get into display quality and this right
here is very impressive the new s22
ultra can go down to one hertz refresh
rate compared to 10 on the iphone 13 pro
max which allows it to save battery life
while using things like always on
display mode but that's actually one of
the things that's rumored for the iphone
14 pro model so hopefully we get that
later this year but in terms of display
quality samsung has one upped apple once
again not only does the s22 ultra have a
higher 1440p resolution compared to
1284p for the 13 pro max but you can now
finally use 120hz at the same time and
that's probably because it comes with a
5 000 milliamp hour battery compared to
4352 on the 13 pro max so it'll be
interesting to see the battery life
difference when mr who's the boss gets
that done but getting back to the
display samsung is now advertising a
massive
1750 peak brightness compared to apple's
1200 nits which is actually a huge
difference and should give you better
looking hdr content now moving over to
authentication the s22 ultra simply has
a single hole punch for the high quality
40 megapixel selfie camera because they
don't use a sophisticated face id like
system instead they have the under
display ultrasonic fingerprint scanner
and to be honest this has been improving
over the years and it's now very good at
what it does however it's still not
perfect because it obviously doesn't
work for anyone who wears gloves and it
has issues when your fingers are wet or
if it's really cold outside in the
winter and now i know face id on the
iphone has caused issues for a lot of
people who wear masks but apple has
finally updated it and fixed every
single issue now allowing face id to
work perfectly fine with a mask on and
even with glasses added on top of that
so it's honestly by far the best
solution out there right now being so
much better than the fingerprint scanner
on the samsung flagship phones but on a
positive note the s pen now comes
included and it fits into the body just
like it did on the previous note so
that's a really nice added bonus but now
getting into some of the other specs i
really like how it comes with wi-fi 6e
and bluetooth 5.2 compared to only wi-fi
6 and bluetooth 5 on the iphone which
honestly was a huge disappointment when
apple revealed it and on top of that the
iphone still has just 6 gigs of ram
compared to 8 on the base model s22
ultra going all the way up to a massive
16 gigabytes which i honestly think is a
bit overkill but it guarantees that apps
simply won't close on you but in terms
of the performance department i'm
honestly a bit disappointed with the new
snapdragon 8 gen 1 ship because it's
barely improved over the old 888 chip in
terms of cpu performance and it's miles
behind the a15 bionic in the iphone and
the same thing goes for the graphics
performance as well which actually got a
nice boost but it's still way behind
apple's five core a15 especially in
terms of power usage which is definitely
a disappointment but one of the major
advantages of samsung's phones is that
they use much better cooling systems
compared to what apple uses so they're
able to handle longer gaming sessions
without the display dimming which isn't
as big of a problem on the new 13 pro
max as it was on the 12 lineup but it's
still there a little bit but with all
that said if we just break everything
down and look at the s22 ultra for what
it is it's probably hands down the best
android phone ever made because it
combines some of the best tech hardware
out there into one device that honestly
looks really nice and clean but unlike
the days of the past this new flagship
is actually a hundred dollars more
expensive than apple's 13 pro max so
it's going to be a tough decision for
people that are in the middle and there
are actually some really awesome iphone
features that you just can't get on a
samsung flagship like magsafe which is
one of my favorite iphone features of
all time since it makes mounting it in
my car so much easier and i also love
the new mac safe wallet and on top of
that apple software has been getting so
good recently that it's really hard to
give up especially with new features
coming soon like tap to pay and even the
digital license feature as well so all
in all i think it's going to be a close
one between these two and it's really
going to come down to both the display
and camera performance which we're going
to be comparing very soon when we get
our hands on this new phone so if you
haven't already subscribed go ahead and
click the circle above to do so right
now and definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]